how did you begin acting again you know
my life is when you it's only during
interviews that I look back and I
realize with fascination how many things
fell into place at certain points in
life which you don't ever expect it to
happen that way you know so here I was
in the US with my medical studies and
residency and career happening and then
I remember sitting with my brother one
day and saying hey you know what I I
really I really really want to act you
know and he said this he sat me down in
a very traditional Indian salicin sit
down and here is a balance okay here's
your doctor balance here's your acting
balance which one is which one is making
you want to you know tilt that way and I
that was a very interesting way to put
because for me I could have easily just
continued on the path of medicine and
not taken this risk of trying to break
away and try to get into films you know
films was not in anywhere in my realm
until that point so that really made me
think I just sat for a second and you
know I literally I saw this whole star
dust falling onto this side of the
imbalance in my in my mind I'm like ah
that sounds so interesting and so
exciting I want to do this too you know
because he said you know if they're both
equal or if this is more important to
you right now then let go of the acting
dream you know why do you want to why do
you want to take that whole risk now
you're you're set in a career path it's
a great path people respect you you like
the field why do you want to do that and
but then it's something inside me it's
it's the the magic of celluloid the
magic of these characters which have
stayed with me since childhood you know
all these beautiful films they have
shaped my destiny in many many ways
films have shaped my destiny so I said
no I'm going to
give it a try I have to do this and I
had no background whatsoever no not a
nobody no connection and film no nothing
I have always been in the performing
arts which is different the traditional
performing arts you know that kind of
thing so I went to an acting course in
Mumbai I took a short break and went to
an acting course and I loved every
moment of it
III just wanted to try it out and say
what whether this is me you know can I
be other characters and and do this and
I loved every moment of it and and yet I
I heard about oh my gosh how difficult
it is to break into acting you know you
may have to to go and knock on office
doors for years without getting the
right parts and audition and at that
point I panicked I was like okay now now
how long do I take this break for you
know because I already have studied
medicine and I'm on that path and I mean
I this is this is okay it's a
distraction I took but but this is not
seeming as easy as I thought it would be
in anyway but see you know destiny works
in strange ways I was said to come back
to the u.s. a week later with my ticket
from India and I got a call from my
diction teacher he was teaching me Hindi
diction because my language was not even
Hindi it my original language was Canada
which is a regional language I grew up
with so I was learning Hindi you know
and he just said hey there's a producer
who's looking for a girl whose
description seemed exactly like you
match it go and meet him and I I grabbed
that opportunity I I knew I was probably
returning to the states back in one week
but I said what have I got to lose I
will go meet this one producer and my
diction teacher respect him he's a very
he's a very reliable person and he
wouldn't like point me in a direction
where it was nothing you know it was
useless or anything like that so I I
caught an autorickshaw you know the
three wheeler that you have a public
vehicle in India I caught I didn't have
a car there at that time I took an auto
rickshaw I rushed to that office and I I
just walked in and I said I'm here to
meet you for this role
and I remember there was the producer
mr. Rakesh not I will never forget they
gave me my break in film you know and
the director was the celebrated artist
international artist mr. MF Hussain who
was a painter and he's no more he's but
he they were both sitting there he was
going to direct that film
they were both sitting in the office so
I walk in the office my very first ever
this kind of an you know it wasn't an
audition but I just walked in to say may
I try for this part and I remember I
walked in and and then I just introduced
myself and he just looked at me and they
looked at each other and they said okay
thank you you may go and I was I didn't
get it I was like I said what can I
speak and they said no no we let you
know thank you and that was it I said
okay and I left and Here I am going back
towards my travel ticketing office and I
get a call saying from the same producer
about two hours later we had at the
office travel office was two hours away
so I was in my in a cab and I guess
saying when are you going to come and
sign the contract you're on that was as
easy as my entry into film was and I
wasn't auditioned I was that I wasn't
asked to speak the lines or anything but
I guess what happened is I was in the
right place at the right time and I just
did not miss that opportunity the reason
I'm bringing this up is many many people
I see in my life right now
they throw away opportunities I mean it
stares me in the face they say oh I'm
too tired maybe next time you know me oh
my gosh no you don't do that this is
where that biggest door in your life
could - it could change your entire day
and I can't explain that I see many
times I try telling people and they look
at me like I'm crazy and I got that
little meeting no I'll do it next week
no you do it now you know so
that's why I'm saying this in so much
detail because that that's all it took
i I did not I I got the phone call from
my diction teacher I took an auto I went
there I just stood there for one minute
I walked out and bang I was in one of
the most beautiful films ever
Gaja Domini and it's a one-of-a-kind
piece and it had the legendary actors of
Indian cinema in it Madhuri Dixit
Shabana Azmi Naseeruddin Shah
Farida Jalal shilpa shirodkar mr. Shah
Rukh Khan made a special appearance so I
was in the midst of all these legends
watching them work in my very first film
and my appearance was beautiful I played
the muse of rabindranath tagore
the the famed poet and the Nobel
laureate and I played his muse he had
written about this beautiful character
abhi Sarika you know in his poetry and I
played her so it was a very artistic
entry into film and and see how it
happened it was amazing and one thing
obviously when one once you're in and
then you you have the talent of the
dedication you of the sincerity I
believe always next doors open and
that's what happened for me it sounds
like then opportunity whispers yes
instead of knocks and you somehow read
those signs like let's do this now
whereas you say you do see other people
that maybe put it off and it may be fear
it's it's or just thinking that there's
more time but then I get fear - I have
fear - but I don't let that stop me I
sometimes get paralyzing fears about
more things you know so many things but
I also realized that the more maturity I
have the more older I get I'm realizing
you have to grab the moment because
really that is all there is really that
is all there is you know you never know
what the next moment how things can
change how things can take off in a
completely different tangent so so take
like you're saying the universe I
believe this and the universe will give
you science very very
gentle intuitive science for whoever
believes in either God or faith or
universe however you put that that that
higher power which is beyond us as
humans is trying to communicate to us in
a certain way in any way well you know
there is it may come through a person a
phone call like you say like that
whisper you know it can be an intuition
within you saying go there today
something will happen that's good but
you need to follow that you know
otherwise life will just pass by and and
like I've read it so many times in
people who are legends you know in the
in the at the end of their lives they
always say have said this I have never
regretted the things I have done I
always regret the things I have not done
you know when I see that actually that
is my biggest fear you know I don't want
to do that I don't want to come to the
end of my life and say I wish I had done
I had taken the courage to do that
you know because you know as a human we
are all we are all with faults we you
know we will make mistakes so at the end
of my life it's okay if I look back and
say oh gosh I made a billion mistakes
but I don't want to reach that point and
say oh I should have tried that that
would have made a difference to my life
my family's life my community's life my
world's life I didn't do it
I don't want to feel that so that is why
I I go forward
you